yeah i could see dude messiah being the
lowest point in the series and if it is
that's amazing
[Music]
when i was in middle school i read a
book
that no one has ever heard of called
dude i read dude i really struggled i
didn't enjoy a lot of it even though i
was captivated you know what got me
through reading dune the first time
uh when i was in eighth grade was the
dune trailer the original dune trailer
from the 80s with the music you know ba
that's good music i would love it if
they get that theme into the new dune
the original dune i genuinely truly
truly truly truly truly want to do a
reread of
especially before 2020 dune comes out
should we even call it 2020 dune we
should really call it the 2021 dune
let's be real warner brothers several
months ago
i felt some kind of need to for whatever
reason read
the sequel to dune i always wanted to i
just never expected i would one day and
then one day i did that's how life works
i guess you never think you're going to
do something and then
one day you you do
i really love dune messiah messiah
dune messiah it's a pretty fast read
honestly especially compared to the
original dune it's
quite short i've heard people describe
it as the transition book between
dune and children of dune it definitely
made me want to read
children of dune like right away i'm
going to read
the rest of the series i gotta get to
god emperor of dune god
emperor of dune is the best dune book
according to quinn's ideas
and he knows his [ __ ] if if he says god
emperor of dune
is the best dune book i believe him dune
messiah takes place a little
uh quite some time after the original
dune
we learned that there's been a situation
going on i don't want to really spoil
dune for anybody but let's just say
that what was set forth in the original
dune did not
the end of dune was kind of like a false
happy ending in a sense and dune messiah
is like all of the realistic messy
parts that happened afterwards the
political
consequences of everything you see also
the major consequences of
paul's prescience i think that's what
it's called his vision his ability to
see the future
and know what's to come this book is
really contained
and isolated and when you really look at
it from just a plot perspective it
doesn't seem like much happens there's a
lot of
conversations in big rooms for some
reason i got like flashbacks to the star
wars prequels not because dune messiah
is bad but because i felt like the
prequels
took some kind of that stately kind of
mannered
way of talking in the way that
characters of dune
speak that doesn't mean that frank
herbert is bad at writing dialogue
it's just different admittedly there are
some cheesy lines
sort of like in the prequel movies
flashbacks and that's one of the
downsides
to june messiah is it feels almost like
a chamber piece
i don't even know what that word means
it just sounds smart but it feels very
contained and it feels almost like the
first
half of a book which makes me want to
read
children of dune but not necessarily for
the right reasons just because i feel
slightly
unsatisfied the ending is wow you know
it's very
shocking tragic can i say tragic it's
very shocking
and moving but again it just it feels
like the first half of
a book i'm really glad that i read dude
messiah though it reminded me
that frank herbert is a good writer i've
read a lot of hate about his writing
style
he's not some kind of like prose stylist
he's no faulkner he's no
tony morrison or anything he he's
writing in a way that
is clear and fits the purposes of his
story
the omniscient view being able to
see everyone's thoughts and motivations
makes it feel
very unique in some ways you know i
wonder if it was like a third person
limited perspective i wonder how
differently the information
would even be conveyed because you're
able to see this massive world because
of the way frank herbert writes that's
that's unique to dune i wouldn't want to
change that for
something that's more pretty or flowery
or more traditional
i like that weirdness and that's what
gives dune
its unique quality for something that's
such a classic as a dune
and the sequels why would we want to
change
the way he he wrote these books because
he wrote them how he wanted to write
them i
really enjoyed it i couldn't read a ton
of books
in this style all the time it's unlike
anything else and i think that's what
helped give it this kind of cult
following in this very loyal fan base
it stands out as different the the
concept the ideas
the execution i thought that reading
dune messiah would feel like a slog or a
chore but
i'm really happy i read it a lot of
people think that dune messiah is the
lowest point in the series the original
six
books written by frank herbert i mean i
could see that i haven't read the other
ones
i would put dune above dune messiah just
because it feels
more full with a story whereas dune
messiah feels almost like an extended
novella yeah i could see doon messiah
being the lowest
point in the series and if it is that's
amazing i hate it when
series uh just kind of like go steadily
downhill because it doesn't give you any
incentive to read more i love it when
not when the first book is like the
weakest but the second book being the
weakest
i'm totally cool with that because i
know that there's other books to get to
and honestly like it didn't feel like
the week a week point in in most series
like it it just
it felt like an important stepping stone
in the story frank herbert was telling
i see why it bothered a lot of people
who who loved the original dune because
it really
flips the preconceptions about what dune
is on its head
and and said to the readers no no this
is this is this is not this
i'm gonna this is my story okay get get
your own story
listen here you youngsters i imagine
frank herbert saying that i
i don't have much more to say about dune
messiah i thought it was really good
sometimes it's hard to get into the
characters heads they are going through
literally experiences no one really
knows like the ability to see the future
if i were to give it a rating it i would
give it like a
15 yeah i think 15 is a good rating if
you're new to the channel
welcome if you're a return viewer
hi i guess like and subscribe it's uh
free apparently that's what they're
telling me i
i'm posting videos uh once a week i
am a consistent part of your life now
every week
a video boom boom isn't that exciting i
mean who else does that
who else that's i mean that's a new idea